how are you Jeff I am great rich how are
you I'm doing fine are you calling in
with the children in your midst right
now where are you I sure AM and I'm
going and sliding into the room with uh
with a lock on the door and with
noise-canceling okay follow them up
against it because I'm trying to be a
pro I appreciate that no four kids
downstairs they're playing with all
kinds of toys and getting into trouble
and I'm just getting away from the whole
thing so now I got a snow day here okay
are they watching Sesame Street is that
why your tweet from just mere moments
ago was Elmo on fire Jeff were something
you know the assumption was that like
the world was coming to an end because
Bryce Harper was going to sign with the
mess or something no actually I was just
on Labatt's hard and I do a really good
Elmo impersonation and and he made me do
he made me answer baseball questions in
my Elmo impersonation and Wow I think I
think people liked it well Jeff since I
have actually made a career out of being
accused by stugots of stealing good
stuff from Dan Levitan show I'm going to
ask you to tell me the latest on Bryce
Harper in Elmo's voice right now Jeff
you know how I'd look maybe you don't
know how it works in this world just yet
since you are building your resume
clearly it is the bit of the person
who's asking you at the very moment dan
Patrick calls it sampling but feel free
to tell me the latest and Bryce Harper
in Elmo's voice go ahead Jeff am I
really going to do this like are you
sure you want to please delude your show
as much as they did there's Jeff every
single thing I do that is original is
being accused by stugots of being ripped
off from him I don't care I don't care
okay you might as well just go for it
and it's been on the show we're showing
video right now our great Los Angeles
broadcasting Center as a crew has just
pulled up Elmo being on like a mic am i
nuking my career in two radio hits is
this what's going on right now you're
right
to each other Jeff I can't ask you again
to do it please give me the latest on
Bryce Harper and Elmo's voice please
[Music]
[Applause]
like started like you know if you have
kids and you have them watching Sesame
Street it's like bleary-eyed
and and you think you can do just
ridiculous things and one day I found
out I could do Elmo and where it's
really worked is I like I will do
inappropriate Elmo and just say untoward
things in my Elmo boy you're speaking
you're speaking of a guy Jeff who's once
upon a time a big show-stopping finish
to a stand-up comedy act was reading the
penthouse forms letters in howard cosell
voice so I get it I get it
so what it's so so Harper was this part
of the gambit the entire time to wait
for Machado to sign before he signs no I
you know on on the contrary I think the
perception in the industry was that
Harper was consigned and Machado was
going to almost draft off of him like a
car and and that if Machado wanted to
get the 300 million that that he that he
desired it was going to be on the tail
of Harper and clearly that is not the
case Manny Machado and his agent Dan
Lozano got the 300 million that he was
looking for guaranteed and and while the
white sox offer was strong it was eight
years two hundred fifty million dollars
options that could have taken it up to
320 million escalators that could have
put it up to about 340 like there was
there was really good money there it was
not the guaranteed 300 and that's what
machado wanted and and I understand why
he he has been around baseball enough
now where he has seen guys careers fall
apart he has seen plate appearances
being manipulated just so options don't
vest
and he understands that money on the
table right now is better than money
that might be earned in the future and
that's why he's gonna be a San Diego
Padre and not a Chicago wife though and
does he have did the white socks not
give him the same out after five or
other bells and whistles that that San
Diego did like why do you think that
yeah the out after five was absolutely a
big deal and it's a big deal because if
things don't go according to plan Manny
Machado still can be a free agent at 31
years old and I know that 31 is not the
same as 26 you know the Padres are
getting the presumably what are going to
be the five best years in those first
five that manny machado is gonna have
but it's not like 31 year olds reaching
the market can't go out and get five or
six year deals i mean we saw Charlie
Blackmon for example resigned with the
with the Colorado Rockies taking him
through age 36 Nolan Nolan Arenado is
discussing a contract extension that
would take him into his mid 30s Mike
Trout when it happens is going to be
extended probably up until he's 40 if he
does choose to stay with the Angels or
if he it's free agency he can get
whatever he wants so it's not like it if
you if you're out at 31 you're not going
to get anything but the likelihood of it
just is not the same as when you're 26
and that that is what made Manny Machado
is attractive as he was to the Padres
and the White Sox and what shocks me is
that they got 300 million without the
Cubs being in without the Yankees being
and without the Red Sox being in without
the Dodgers being and without the Giants
being in those are the five biggest
earning teams in baseball none of them
was really in on Machado and he still
got three hundred million dollars
it's the Honda inside a report otherwise
known as Passons world Jeff Passan here
on the Rich Eisen show so who's more
happy about the fact that the San Diego
Padres the San Diego Padres gave the
richest contract in the history of
American sports of 300 million dollars
in Southern California to Manning mature
who's more happy Rob Manfred with
everything being discussed about the
suppression of the free agent market or
Mike Trout Jeff I I think Nolan Arenado
is probably happier than my trap just
because honestly trout's gonna get paid
rich like no matter what route like we
may be looking at the best baseball
player ever and it's weird to say that
as it's going on and at me you know
there needs to be more time Mike Trout
has has a legitimate chance to be the
best player ever and he's going to get
paid Nolan Arenado though has has every
reason in the world to hold out for 300
million dollars plus now because most
people in the game think he's a better
player than Manny Machado and and you
know all the issues that vexed Machado
whether it's attitude whether it's
hustle some of the things that that you
know put teams off on him none of that's
there were there now the only thing the
only knock you've got against Arenado is
that he plays a course field and that
his splits are pretty considerable but
this is a guy who's been more consistent
than Machado he's he's just an awesome
player and he's a free agent after the
season and the Rockies want to get a
deal done that's going to be hard but
the the Rob Manfred points is an
important one I I want to make this
abundantly clear one or two contracts
does not mean that there is not
collusion going on in baseball I do not
believe there is evidence to show that
there's collusion going on but let's
remember what collusion is it's not
exactly necessarily broadly defined you
can collude against particular segments
of the market and if the collusion case
the MLBPA ever brings does come to
fruition it's going to be against older
players that and and Manny Machado and
Bryce Harper are both in their 20s now I
have no inside information that a
collusion case is going to be broke be
brought anytime soon but I do know that
back in back when the owners were
colluding in the 80s the first case that
was brought against them there wasn't a
whole lot of evidence there was a
smoking gun that was only later found
and so the idea that there can't be a
case without a smoking gun just isn't
true but the the Union knows that
has to tread very carefully because this
is such a loaded accusation well just in
terms of being a fan and I'm a huge fan
of the sport and you know I really when
I was at ESPN a covered baseball I did
baseball games I cannot get enough of
the sport as a fan I'd rather see a
clock instituted in the offseason rather
than during the playing season because
this is ridiculous that here we are with
spring training open and Harper is just
the top name of a whole bunch of names
of players who have not signed yet
and I'm like there's some guy cycles the
guys want to say young Craig Kimbrel you
know gotten off to the best start for a
closer in baseball history so does
baseball like it does baseball like it
that they're that free agency and the
signing is gonna come in a burst right
before the season as opposed to what the
NBA and the NFL does which is spark
interest in the sport for a 10-day
period in the non-playing season just
hey here's the reason why I think the
NFL is able to do that and the NBA is
able to do that because their salary cap
sports rich and when you have a salary
cap there's a certain level to which a
player understands and recognizes his
contract can go and he fits in a
particular place in this paradigm that
has been well established based on the
amount of revenue that is generated in
the sport baseball has no such thing in
place it doesn't have a ceiling it
doesn't have a floor and because it
doesn't have either of these things
players are valued by the open market
what's happened is that this free market
that the MLB PA spent so long fighting
for has changed and has shifted and it
shifted underneath the the players feet
like a tectonic plate and has really
shaken them because as salaries are
depressed over the first six maybe seven
years of your career rich in terms of
pre arbitration salaries and then even
an arbitration you're not getting paid
nearly as much as you would on the
market the expectation has been that
once we reach free agency we're going to
get paid they're going to give us are
come up at that point that's not
happening now and when you're not
getting paid on the front end what
think you should and when you're not
getting paid on the back end what you
think you should that's where the
cognitive dissonance arrives and where
you have players every day tweeting
about how the system's broken last one
for you Jeff Passan in the Honda insider
report to me the issue isn't pace of
play I don't care how long it takes the
game and I don't think my kids do either
I've got ten eight and five at home who
whenever I do radio and podcast hits
I also lock out of the room just like
you've done right now Jeff so they don't
care about how long the game takes what
I see they care about what I care about
is how long it takes to have a ball put
in play not pace up a quality of play
and the pace of quality of play to me
the way to fix that is fixing the shift
why is this so difficult for baseball to
wrap their arms around Jeff well let me
let me let me play devil's advocate
please what does it what does the shift
typically take away rich what it takes
away is a discerning hitter in my mind
the answer I was going for there with
singles because that that is what in in
actuality it takes away a bunch of
singles and you're not going to the
ballpark for singles but your point is
really well-made
because left-handed hitters especially
now feel they have to lift the ball they
do because you're gonna have a guy in
deep right field and you're gonna have a
guy on the right hand side or the left
hand side excuse me if you're looking at
the bag itself you have a guy on the
right side of the infield from shortstop
or third base whatever is you're gonna
have two three guys over there and to
get the ball by those guys if you're a
left-handed pull hitter you have to lift
it and if you're trying to lift the ball
you are likelier to swing and miss and
if you're likely to swing and miss
that's one of the reasons that
strikeouts have gone up the way that
they have the amount of strikeouts in
baseball right now is really troublesome
but I also think personally from what
I've seen with my kids and and with
others that baseball's biggest issue
right now is demographic I I think that
a generation of fans whether it is
because of how fast the game is going
right now or how slow I guess it's going
in a lot of cases
and because there aren't stars in the
sport have a really tough time
connecting with baseball and they look
at baseball as a boring sport and that
is the last thing you want to be in the
short attention span there and 2019 that
we have you don't want to be boring and
in baseball right now to me has that
issue that is so much more important
than any of these other things that
they're fighting about all right last
one for you spring training games begin
tomorrow how do you see the Bryce Harper
situation playing it out and I like it
in the voice of growver please then
short of that how do you see that how do
you see the Bryce Harper thing playing
out with spring training games starting
Thursday somebody yesterday said to me
this is going to play out like JD
Martinez in Boston did last year
the Phillies know that they want Bryce
Harper Bryce Harper recognizes that the
Phillies are the best opportunity for
him there's going to be a bit of a
staring contest they're gonna haggle but
ultimately the two sides are gonna
understand that they're the best fit for
each other but while I say that and
while I believe that the Washington
Nationals rich are always lurking in the
background and the idea that this player
who they've known since he was 17 18
years old it's suddenly going to be
playing for their division rival that
it's fortified itself significantly this
offseason and could usurp them
ultimately over the next five years has
to be something that's on the minds of
the Nationals people as this decision
comes down to the end and you don't
think the rumor about a Giants signing
possibility Spurs the Dodgers into some
form of action nope okay I think the
Giants I think the Giants are in there
is well potentially but I I don't think
the Dodgers have any inclination to go a
long term and I'm not sure at this point
that the Giants do either is going
short-term doesn't make much sense for
them because frankly over the next
couple of years they're probably not
going to be very good and there's no
famed Boras secret team there is I
always believe that there is a mystery
team somewhere in there who would that
be
Indians White Sox Cubs oh my god yeah
you know the White Sox have been in
conversation with them still I don't
know that they're gonna go to a place
where Scott Boras says he is right now
which is well well over 300 million
dollars at the same time if the market
comes back to them then I I know that
they really impressed Bryce Harper
in his meeting with them Jim Thome was
in that meeting and Jim Thome is a
beloved guy I'm not going to count the
White Sox out
I just don't know they're at the
forefront right now I think it's
Phillies or bust but look these things
can change with one phone call all right
go back to your kids Jeff appreciate the
time always enjoy your work as well I
look forward to the next chat Thanks
take a that's Jeff Passan at Jeff Passan
on Twitter in the Honda inside a report
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience